se poser et bien regarder avec rioual
bernis honneur souhaite vous faire
ralentir pour comprendre ce qu'il se
passe ce qui compose son un veau qui
donne le nom à l'exposition
vraiment c'est aussi un apprentissage de
l'observation parce qu'on a besoin
aujourd'hui le on a un problème avec le
temps on court toujours après le temps
et on a besoin en vain compte de
ralentir pour pouvoir mieux observer
pour pouvoir mieux apprécier ce qui nous
entoure et de notre relation avec la
nature passe souvent par par une étape
d'observation de connaissances et
d'apprentissage ils sont cinq artistes
exposés autour du ray ensauvagement 3 ar
se répondent ils sont peintres designers
ou artistes numériques avec un but
mettre en valeur la nature et le rapport
de l'homme avec cette nature c'est
important de voir le regard des autres
sur un même point
c'est un rapport évidemment avec
l'abstraction avec chacun chacun son
regard sur sur les choses
et surtout ça réunit des forces on a
besoin de réunir des forces pour pour
qu'un message soit plus fort c'est
important d'avoir différentes versions
sur un même message l'exposition à
l'initiative de bernis honneur veut
amener à une réflexion sur la nature et
sur la vie une réflexion à développer à
travers une trentaine d'oeuvres